Coffee is the second most traded
commodity after oil socially and
ecologically it still represents a big
chunk of Guatemala's economy Guatemala's
social networks and biodiversity
sustainability as well and recent
outbreaks of pests and infestations
linked with the low prices chrome in the
market have bit more pressure on the
public farmers and the beetles are gonna
attack your coffee again is do that how
disconnects also to that price if
there's too many of these if price goes
low
it was really eye-opening to look at how
many communities were really on the
razor edge of not having enough water by
the end of the dry season like literally
not having to water their crops who
they're going to feed their families or
the food they counted on to sell to have
money to buy the things they needed
how does depended so very narrowly and
so very particularly on the climate of
that year
[Music]
most of Guatemala is playing fed
agriculture coffee
sugarcane all the vegetables we produce
they are entirely related to
precipitation every time we have a
drought it hits these populations really
hard millions of people are in this
vulnerable state where climate
variability let alone climate change
challenges our livelihood sure but it
reflects a larger challenge and people
in agriculture are tied so tightly to
the timing of the amount of rainfall
that comes during the wet season there's
not much heavier climate work at the
timescales that might help inform
agriculture over years decades so what
we're trying to do is fill this really
rather large and really serious gap in
our knowledge about the climate system
and then better policy better management
better planning will come with better
information you'll replace more
frequently so the currently frost
crisis in Central America has been
linked to an increase in temperature if
I drop this in touch to this coffee
plant its transmitted that way too and
we're bringing now this historical
record some precipitation to to try to
understand those connections and try to
manage better the risk so the
communities can be better prepared here
in Guatemala they're looking where to
plant coffee and asking very specific
local research questions it's going to
make a much broader range of information
available to these communities and to
Guatemala and Honduras in Central
America in general and then each
stakeholder in each government in each
community will hopefully be able to draw
some information as useful for that
you know this stuff is happening we are
facing droughts and we're facing more
extreme precipitation events the fact
that we're bringing climate information
to them allows them to better manage
this risk so we have this connection
between climate prices and pasinetta
stations then that improves their
ability to succeed
[Music]
you